you want
Glory to Ukraine
in order to disable Russian
aircraft with
reactive unmanned aerial vehicles of
Soviet
production and the Angelsaratov region by
means of air defense of the
Russian
Aerospace Forces, Ukrainian UAVs flying at low altitude were intercepted as a
result of a fall and explosion at
Russian airfields of fragments of
reactive drones, the
skin of the
hulls of two aircraft was slightly damaged  three Russian
servicemen of the technical staff
who were at the airfield were
mortally wounded four more
servicemen who were wounded were
taken to medical institutions where they were
provided with all the necessary medical
care
didn’t stand by the engine room didn’t see off the
son and the daughter-in-law of the
son of Nevisca live there sat down and
went out to see them off and that’s all and
she stayed smile damn he’s already in the hut everything is also
destroyed